Jacob: I'm Jacob Clifford.
Adriene: And I'm Adriene Hill.
Jacob: And today, finally, Crash Course, is
gonna live up to its name. We're gonna talk
about crashes - economic crashes.
Adriene: Crash Course - we've been waiting
for this!
[Theme Music]
Adriene: In Germany in 1923, people were doing
strange things like using money to wallpaper
their houses and burning money for heat. What
was going on? Had they all gone crazy?
Nope! In the early 1920's, Germany was in
the grip of something called hyperinflation.
In order to pay massive reparations to the
Allies after World War I, Germany printed
a lot of their currency - the Mark.
One result of all this additional money was
higher and higher prices. By November 1923,
it took a trillion marks to buy one U.S. dollar.
There were one thousand billion mark notes
in circulation. The mark was effectively meaningless.
A similar situation developed in Zimbabwe
a few years ago. Starting in 2007, inflation
grew rapidly, like really really rapidly.
By September 2008, the International Monetary
Fund estimated the annual inflation rate at
489 billion percent.
In practical terms, the Zimbabwean dollar
lost 99.9% of its value between 2007 and 2008.
It's hard to even imagine what that looks
like. Prices nearly doubled every 24 hours
and businesses revised prices several times
a day.
In June 2008, The Economic Times reported that,
"A loaf of bread now cost what 12 new cards did a decade ago."
The government issued currency in huge denominations
to keep up with rising prices. The million
dollar bill, the billion dollar bill, and
finally in 2009, the hundred trillion dollar
bill - the largest denomination of currency
ever issued. The good news
was that everyone was a billionaire. But the bad
news was that those dollars were virtually worthless.
Jacob: One definition of hyperinflation is
when a country experiences a monthly inflation
rate of over 50% or around 13,000% annual
inflation.
But believe it or not, Zimbabwe's recent inflation
isn't unique, and it's not the worst inflation in history.
In fact the worst was in Hungary in 1946.
Between July 1945 and August 1946, the price
level in Hungary rose by a factor of three
times ten to the twenty-fifth. And yes, any
time you have to express your inflation rate
using scientific notation, that's a bad thing.
Besides the obvious confusion over what prices
to charge for things, why is hyperinflation so bad?
Well inflation, and especially hyperinflation,
erodes wealth. In Zimbabwe, people who had
worked their whole lives and saved up for
retirement, saw their savings just wiped out.
Extreme inflation also forces people to spend
as quickly as possible rather than save or
lend, so there is no money available to fund
new businesses. And all that uncertainty limits
foreign investment and trade.
So, hyperinflation is bad. But how does it
happen? Let's go to the Thought Bubble.
Adriene: So, we're simplifying this stuff a lot.
But the root of the problem in both Weimar Germany
and Zimbabwe was that the government
was paying their bills by printing new money.
An increase in the money supply can have two
effects. It can increase output or increase
prices or some combination of the two. Inflation
starts when output is pushed to capacity and
can't rise much further, but policy makers
continue to increase the money supply.
In theory, once output is maximized, the more money
you print, the more inflation you'll get. Simple, right?
Well, that doesn't fully explain why Germany's
or Zimbabwe's inflation rose exponentially.
Was the government really printing that much
money? Not exactly.
After a couple years of doubling prices, people
started to expect high inflation, and that
changed their behavior. Say you're planning
to buy a new refrigerator, and you expect
prices to rise quickly. You buy it as soon
as possible before the price has had a chance
to change. But with everyone following that
logic, dollars start to circulate faster and
faster and faster.
Economists called the number of times a dollar
is spent per year the velocity of money. When
people spend their money as quickly as they
get it, that increases velocity, which pushes
inflation up even faster.
You get a vicious cycle of higher prices,
which lead to expectations of higher prices,
which lead to higher prices.
The hyperinflation in Germany ended when the
government replaced the worthless mark with
a new currency. Zimbabwe ended its hyperinflation
by abandoning its currency altogether. Now,
its citizens use U.S. dollars or currencies
from neighboring countries.
The good news is that prices have since stabilized
and real GDP has begun to increase.
Jacob: Thanks Thought Bubble.
So, if you ever control a national economy,
try to avoid hyperinflation. You might also
want to stay away from depressions.
A depression is kind of a hard thing to define,
but basically it's when real GP falls and
keeps falling for a long period of time. This
has all sorts of terrible effects like high
unemployment and falling prices.
Before the 1930's, economists use the term
depression to describe sustained falls in
GDP. But after The Great Depression, economists
started using the word recession for downturns
to avoid association with the 1930's.
I guess calling it a depression was just too
depressing.
When the stock market crashed in 1929, it
didn't just cause problems for stock brokers.
Everyone freaked out and stopped spending,
and the economy ground to a halt.
Of course, that's not the only reason for
The Great Depression. Actually, there's still
a lot of debate about the causes.
Anyway, when economies fall into deep recessions,
there are more workers than there are jobs
and more output than consumers want to buy.
So both income and prices fall.
Central banks can try to use Expansionary
Monetary Policy to speed up the economy. So
for example, in the U.S. The Federal Reserve
can lower interest rates. This encourages
consumers and businesses to take out loans,
and hopefully, get the economy going again.
But if people start changing their expectations
and anticipate further price declines, they'll
change their behavior in ways that work against
the central bank.
Like, if you're planning to buy a refrigerator
and you expect prices to fall, you're gonna
wait to get a lower price. But, if everyone
follows that same logic, then spending declines
and so does the velocity of money.
That leads to further price declines and a
vicious cycle of falling prices, which leads
to expectations of lower prices, which actually
leads to lower prices. It also leads to layoffs
at the refrigerator factory and so on and
so on and so on.
This is called a liquidity trap and some economists
believe it's a worsening factor in economic
downturns including The Great Depression.
Adriene: Speaking of The Great Depression,
after the initial crash of 1929, The Federal
Reserve dropped interest rates to zero, output
and prices fell, and regular people started
to expect further price declines. Unemployment
rose to 25%, and the average family income
dropped by around 40%.
This is...not great. Once interest rates hit
zero, and prices were still falling, the central
bank was in a bind. Continuing deflation meant that
borrowing money was a bad deal, even with no interest.
The money you pay back in the future would
have more buying power than the money you
originally borrowed. This discouraged people
from buying homes or cars and discouraged
businesses from borrowing to expand capacity.
In fact, getting out of The Depression took
nearly a decade. And it wasn't really monetary
policy that put an end to it. It was the massive
government spending of World War II.
Okay, you don't want hyperinflation. You don't
want depressions. You also don't want stagflation.
That's when output slows down or stops or
stagnates at the same time that prices rise.
So, stagnant economy plus inflation equals
stagflation. Get it? It's a portmanteau.
Jacob: The U.S. experienced stagflation starting
in the 1970's, after a series of supply shocks
including a rise in oil prices and, believe it or not,
a die-off of Peruvian anchovies, which were important
for animal feed and fertilizers. This combination of
events meant the economy couldn't produce as much.
The Fed tried to address this by boosting
the money supply and cutting interest rates,
but output couldn't rise much because of low
productivity and the oil shortage. So, all
that extra money just triggered inflation.
It got even worse when people began to adjust their
inflation expectations. Businesses started to expect
costs to rise even further, so they laid off workers,
and that put the economy back into a recession.
When The Fed boosted the money supply again,
that raised inflation expectations even more.
This ended in the early 80's when a new Federal
Reserve Chairman took over. His name was Paul
Volcker. He actually cut the money supply
and raised interest rates dramatically.
Output plummeted, and unemployment reached
ten percent, but prices stopped rising and
so did inflation expectations.
The economy gradually recovered, and Paul
Volcker got the credit for ending stagflation.
So hyperinflation, deflation, depression,
stagflation - they're all extreme economic
circumstances, but these extremes show us why it's
so important to measure and understand the overall economy.
In some cases, government action or inaction
made things worse. And in other cases, the
government helped the economy get back on
its feet.
But it's important to keep in mind that the economy
is made up of collective decisions of individuals.
It's people like us, our expectations matter.
If enough people fear a recession, they're
gonna decrease their spending, and that's
gonna cause a recession.
Adriene: Next week, we're gonna look at different
economic schools of thought. But regardless
of philosophy, policies designed to steer
the economy need to address expectations and
focus on creating confidence.
Jacob: Thanks for watching. We'll see you
next week.
Thanks for watching Crash Course Economics.
It's made with the help of all these awesome
people. You can help keep Crash Course free,
for everyone, forever by supporting it at
Patreon. Patreon is a voluntary subscription
service where you can support the show with
a monthly contribution. We'd also like to
thank our High Chancellor of Learning, Dr.
Brett Henderson and our Headmaster of Learning,
Linea Boyev. Also, our Crash Course Vice Principals,
Cathy and Tim Phillip.
Thanks for watching! DFTBA